so whether I left off in the last video
we had we had kind of talked about the
scenario where my buddies and I we came
up with this idea to sell socks online
we went to a rich investor we call an
angel investor who's usually kind of a a
rich uncle type of figure who gets
excited by young guys innovating in the
world and we say hey we need five
million dollars he says sure enough I
think the idea you have by itself or
maybe some kind of prototype you might
have made or something that's worth five
million dollars so I'll give you another
five million dollars of cash to kind of
get started rent some space hire some
people and for that since what you had
was five million that's what you're
bringing to the table I'm bringing five
million dollars cash the table I
essentially get half the company and the
way that works is it's not like we gave
we each gave him half of our shares
instead since we are the board of the
company we issue another million shares
so we double the share count and we give
it to him
and this pre-money valuation is really
really important because if we if we had
agreed if we said this wasn't five
million if we said that this is I don't
know let's say if we if you know he is a
hard negotiator he says no that's only
worth a million dollars right and I'm
going to give five million dollars right
so let me ask you how many shares would
we have to issue so think about it he's
if he was a hard negotiate down here so
I don't want to mess up the issue if he
because our idea I mean it really is a
hard thing to estimate what an idea is
worth so he negotiates hard in the end
of day were desperate financial markets
have collapsed so we'll take money from
whoever's willing to give it to us and
we really want to quit our jobs so he
says that's that that what we have right
now our idea is only worth a million
dollars right and he's going to give us
five million dollars so how many shares
do we have to give him this right here
this is a million shares right that's
what we started off with so when he says
that what we have right now is worth a
million dollars he's essentially saying
that it's worth $1 per share $1 per
share so my 200,000 shares are worth
$200,000 according to his valuation up
here we said that what we had before was
with Phi
million dollars in the previous video
right if what we had before is worth
five million dollars and there were a
million shares initially right this was
the million shares then the pre-money
valuation I have actually the valuation
either pre or post money would be five
dollars per share five dollars per share
and in the five dollar per share world
what we did is we issued another million
shares and sold them for five million
dollars or we sell them for $5 per share
right to get the five million dollars
and so if we ended up with a 50/50 split
of the company right this is the angel
investor angel and this is all of us
down here and this is all of this is
equity no no debt no liabilities just
yet now in this reality if he's valuing
what we have right now is essentially $1
per share he says worth a million
dollars you have a million shares it's
$1 per share in order for him to give
five million dollars he's essentially
going to buy five million dollars worth
of stock at $1 per share so he's
essentially going to need five million
shares five million shares and notice in
the situation up here before when I have
when I have two hundred thousand shares
well when I had 1/5 of a million of five
million dollars that was five million
when I had one fifth of five million
dollars the value of my shares was 1
million dollars right and then when I
have tenth when I have one tenth of two
million shares oh I still have one tenth
of ten million dollars of total asset
value because now he threw in this his
five million dollars and so my share is
still worth 1 million dollars Evan I
have a tenth of 10 million as opposed to
a fifth of 5 million in this situation I
used to have a fifth of to of 1 million
which would be $200,000 and now I have
200,000 over how many total shares are
there now there now 6 million shares
right so now I have one 60th right is
that right
I have 200,000 and now have 200,000 over
six six million right that's six
thousand thousands that cancels out I
now own one thirtieth of the company
right before I had one fifth and we're
valuing it at six million right because
I have a million here and five million
here times six million and so what's one
thirtieth of six million one six over 30
is equal to one fifth of a million so
this is still two hundred thousand
dollars so no matter what I do my the
between the pre-money and the post-money
valuation my per share value doesn't
change any and I want to show you that
but this matters a lot
right because based on what this
pre-money valuation is it tells us how
many how many shares what percentage of
the company our angel investor gets for
investing in his five million dollars in
this case he gets five sixths of the
company five said what is that five
times that's like 80 percent of the
company I think roughly and we are left
with the other know one-sixth is right
one six notice more than eighty is like
eighty four percent and we're left with
like sixteen percent of the company so
it's a very different scenario depending
on what our pre-money valuation is and
of course the pre-money valuation is
just you just take the pre-money
valuation plus the amount of cash
they're given and that's the post-money
valuation right the amount of money you
get you know pre pre money and then post
money you add the money in and that's
you get the six million dollar valuation
fair enough I think I've I've beaten
this horse dead now I think you have a
good sense of it let's say let's say
that we end up lucky the guy that wasn't
a hard negotiator and we ended up with
that first that first situation so let
me redraw it so now if we if I were to
draw the assets of this corporation the
assets of this corporation at least at
the time of that guy's investment we're
it's a very intangible asset we call it
the idea it now has a value five million
dollars and we have some cash we have
five million in cash
five million in cash and then if we do
the shares let me do that another box oh
there you go there the shares and all of
that chair we'll have two million shares
outstanding two million shares I have 1
million to the angel investor angel so
he has 50% of the shares and just
because I like to keep track of my slice
there's 200,000 shares that go to sell
fair enough now I mean obviously the
whole point of this wasn't just to
negotiate and raise money and quit our
jobs the whole point of this was to
start a business so let's say we take
this 5 million dollars we start hiring
people and really our first step is to
build out our website and just kind of
have a a working site going so let's say
we we burn through 4 million dollars of
that and we build a site so let's say we
only have a million dollars left this is
you know maybe six months in the future
we all quit our jobs we got some fancy
loft-like office space
we got a foosball table and we also
built a website we hired some graphic
designers and things and so we've burned
through most of our cash and we're
starting to get a little bit worried
because we haven't made a profit yet but
we have a neat website we have a neat
website right something that you know
when we went to the angel investors we
just had a we just had an idea a
business plan and we just have you know
we just hopefully we had our charisma
and we were able to sell the guy on the
idea he thought it was you know we're
going to be the next the next dominant
soccer player in the world but now we
actually built something we took his
money and as promised we built a nice
website and now we need to raise money
more money one because we've hired 50
people and this million dollars is going
to last us too long and that would be a
shame to to run out of cash just when
we're getting off the ground we now
actually have a real website and offices
and all of that and we want to raise
some money because we want to we want to
put up some AdWords on Google so people
know about our site we want to spend you
know a couple million dollars for a
Superbowl ad so people know that they
can get Sox online now so we have to
raise more money and now at this stage
we
go back to the venture capital community
but we wouldn't go to the Angels the
angels are the guys who like the big
picture who want you know just to kind
of throw some money into an early idea
and they it's usually a relatively small
amount actually five million dollars
would be a large amount for an angel we
want to go to kind of real professional
VCS now and what we would do is we would
go to a seed VC sow seed VCS are kind of
the the first round and each round is
kind of every time you have to go back
to the till to raise money that's kind
of a round of financing but seed
investors so there's a lot of words for
it but seed investors are are usually VC
investors who are actual professionals
at what they do they're actually
managing other people's money and we'll
do another video on how they raise that
money and it's very related to how
private equity firms and and hedge funds
also raise their money but they are
usually managing other people's money
well while a angel investors usually you
know he's just sitting on top of a big
pile of money and likes to play with it
so they're managing other people's money
and they tend to you know have some
fancy MBAs that they just hired will
make models and do projections and and
negotiate a little bit harder with you
when you're when you're actually trying
to get a value on your business but we
have to go to these guys now they have
some value I mean they'll connect us
with other dudes and they'll you know
they have experience starting businesses
they can introduce us to other people
who've done similar things and all the
rest help us network and help us manage
the business so we go to a venture
capitalist and we get the door closed a
lot of times on this but one venture
capitalist one seed venture capitalist
finally comes to us and the terminology
can be a little bit big use here but
we'll call it our series a financing
series a sometimes it'll be called your
seed financing but we'll call it series
a because we want to formalize it and
just so you know the a is because it's
our first real formal round of financing
in our second round which I'll do
probably in the next video it'll be
Series B and then Series C and then
Series D every time we run out of cash
we want to go back to the till we've
already done a Series A now we want to
do a series B in a Serie C and so forth
and so on and eventually we will
hopefully get to some type of an IPO
which I'll talk about in the next video
because I just realized I'm out of time
again